who else is there
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back
the Dead Space
the deadliest space could I get anything
besides pulse round or are you punishing
me for not using it in the first place
I feel like I should be getting more
plasma cutter rounds but I'm not
100 credits that's hardly anything
is there a button to make me go up wait
one second one second
five
fine no weirdly enough
there is not
let me land here I'm just exploring to
see if there's anything else that's
important
apparently there's not gravity control
oh
ah but it still don't do nothing for me
here
okay thank you
and more pulse rounds great
and more pulse rounds
I love both rounds well I found myself a
uh
thingama Bob
hey come back here oh finally
all right where is this supposed to go
this seems important
it's one of those power do hickeys so if
you could just tell me where it goes
it'd be greatly appreciated I almost
missed the diving frantically for a
surface that I can attach to
it wasn't like the most uh elegant way
to travel but it was pretty cool
but the 3D maneuvering is also fun too I
can't I can't deny I hope you're not
expecting me to go too far beyond
ooh this looks like a thing I see power
cables anyway which probably means that
there's some place to put this
huh
track control offline well the power's
good down there but why that doesn't
make much sense
I thought I'd whoa it's right there in
front of my eyeballs
why
why does it keep doing that why does it
keep why does it keep doing that
oh
loading shutter what is loading shutter
what is this
see I don't really remember what you
were telling me to do in the first place
so uh whoa It's got goodies
lots of goodies holy crap
exploration pays everybody exploration
pays literally money
come on grab grab it
grab it
really doesn't want me to have plasma
cutter ammo it knows I upgraded it so
it's like oh no that would make the game
too easy
okay ignore the fact that it just gave
me plasma cut around ammo but
I'm trying to be I'm trying to be Petty
what are you
oh three
how rich do you think I am
I can afford level three clearance
not in your life all right where else
does this go
cargo rail tracks whatever that means
nobody really knows what that means
okay
track control
sure
what did I just do
oh I don't know what that's for
oh
okay so obviously that's for pulling
something out but I'm not even ready to
get there yet
supposed to go down
ah I need to get out the doors okay I'll
stop wait a minute I might be able to
get that audio log that was in the ship
over there because the wreckage is still
there
probably poor Johnston's dead corpse is
floating ominously but hey
I'm still alive so that's all that
matters for me it doesn't look like it
that's pretty beat up
okay whatever
it's gone forever and that's fine
not gonna cry about it too much
oh Johnston
oh
Johnston no
oh your whole face got blown off
oh you're literally your face got blown
off
oh and your ankles the only thing that's
left oh the irony of it all
because she broke her ankle it's very
sad it's very sad shouldn't be making
jokes all right let's get out of here
they have been really sparse about the
like items that they've been giving out
Man by the time I'm actually going to be
able to go
like on to harder difficulties which I
am going to do in this game I'm very
happy to do that
I'm gonna just have a really rough time
of the difficulty I know that sentence
took way longer than it should have but
I was really thinking my brain had to
really come up with the words what are
you uh not you not you you you you you
you you you you you you you
ah volker's rig
who is volcker
am I supposed to know who that is is
that you that's peculiar
I'm not sure why I got that uh something
over here
nothing over there
get some oxygen real quick babies
oh God damn oh you're not dead are you
no I threw the money no the money
but the money is what it's all about
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah Isaac okay
yeah
yeah oh
all right
this looks fun
[Music]
oh it gets goopy down there Ah that's
concerning oh it's pulsing
oh it's got a pulse
I better hurry up I'm running out of
oxygen yeah I know I know I know I know
I was goofing around I don't know why
was that an oxygen tank was that usable
oxygen yeah this use
thank you
oh
they're giving me a lot of explodies but
I'm not saying things to explode I gotta
assume they're coming I gotta get going
they're not gonna give me many more of
those
okay and and please what
okay I thought something was in there
with me but it turns out I'm stupid hey
look oh sick
we are not punished for our sins but by
them
hey there's someone else in a
kind of suit like mine I've never seen
sorry no uh
no personalsies
more pulse rounds
I get it I get it I'm gonna use the dang
pulse rifle I'm gonna use it I should
have upgraded it but I didn't oh my God
oh
what are you doing
what are you doing now what are you
doing to me why are you doing that
adding this to my maintenance priority
request maybe something in writing will
make them pay attention that
unidentified growth reported Elsewhere
on the ship has reached engineering not
even medical knows what the hell this
stuff is it looks like someone threw up
their guts all over the walls it smells
about the same spreading faster than we
can cut it up which is pretty disgusting
in and of itself it's already busted the
cargo lift and it's getting into the
engine spoke if we can't find a way to
stop it soon it'll be all over the main
engine chamber about the day after
tomorrow meantime I'm heading to the
mining deck they've got pfm 100s in
storage for ice Mining and they can
spare the fuel maybe cauterizing the
stuff will do the trick just hope it
doesn't smell worse when it's on fire
organic matter detected in what
that announcement actually had something
pertinent it wasn't just nonsense it's
that organic
correct course immediately
I'm working on it
I'm just one engineer
I can only do so much
oh
[Music]
all right find autopsy location in
engineering okay
or hearing log acting chief engineer
Jacob Temple reporting
still can't believe the chief is gone
it's all Fallen apart since the captain
died everyone down here is on their last
Nerf we thought the rioting was the
worst of it so those things came through
the vents
faces
[__] those were my Lunch Buddies Liz's
friends old boyfriends and out of
nowhere the engines are screwed
primaries laboring were hemorrhaging
fuels [__] if I know why
taking Danvers to the Fuel Depot to fix
it gotta keep the team focused or a
little crack
triple out man I don't even know how
people would be operating and keeping
the ship together when everything is
like messed up like this and creatures
are everywhere
yeah they're out of fuel the centrifuge
is offline we're Tethered to a four
trillion ton payload without the engines
it's dragging us down to the planet can
you handle it alone
sure fix the centrifuge get the fuel
running and do a full restart
but you'll need to stabilize their orbit
from there standing by fast as you can
Isaac
yeah fast as I can when there's a
billion Necromorphs trying to kill me
how many people even worked on this ship
if it's anything like an aircraft
carrier they could be like 5 000 people
on an aircraft carrier and it seems like
this this thing might be a lot bigger
than in aircraft carriers for all I know
Frick there might be
tens of thousands of people on there
makes sense
uh to centrifuge I like centrifuges
I don't know if this is the best way to
go I don't even know if it's the right
way to go but I'm gonna just like go
if it's allowing me to be non-linear I'm
going to be non-linear I'm just going to
go the first place I see
okay
mandatory decontamination I can
understand that I can respect that even
I can appreciate that
ugh all right
hey security clearance thank you
oh yeah
all right
goodies lots of goodies but tiny itty
bitty goodies like I like goodies I do
I almost wish there were more goodies
check-in time 7 38 more absences it's
not just the unitologist sneaking off
for religious exemptions
what is with it
the interference pattern on the notes
we're seeing serious gaps in the
rotation people going on sick with sleep
deprivation self-inflicted injuries are
just disappearing they go off shift and
they don't come back someone said the
ship's been attacked [__] we're at
the ass end of nowhere who'd come all
this way to attack a mining ship and
yeah the captain is dead but CarMax has
one of the bridge staff killed him I
swear to God the rumors on this deck are
out of control update lost contact with
the bridge no rig link no security
Hardline nothing okay this is beyond
rumors [__] this I'm good now while I
still can yeah but where though
yeah but where where are you gonna go I
don't know if you got anywhere to go
kind of difficult
maybe I should have gone to the store
didn't realize nah I'm gonna chew it up
soon
I'm gonna start shooting things and then
everything God this escape button it's
too sticky oh no
no oh no
oh I should have grabbed the stasis bomb
did please stand by
foreign
oh
oh whoops oh God
what's that supposed to be what
thank you for your patience
oh
oh wait a minute
is that a proximity mine or something
I didn't know that's what that was I'm
learning something new every day that's
why it wouldn't explode sometimes
oh it explodes when people come near it
and by people I mean former people that
are now monstrous alien
morph things
someone having a bad time in here
sounds like someone's not having a very
good time
oh this is a long hallway
oh oh oh
[Music]
well there's cradling it like a baby
I don't like that
hey our baby
stop it
how
yeah that's what I thought
[Music]
get this centrifuge up and running and
everything will be just fine
[Music]
why no that's an arm
yeah
Tai zhangi there what's keeping them the
centrifice is still offline we're
running out of time no wriggling
contacts since they left Chief they're
gone aren't they but we had armed him
with everything we had they just sent
word if there was trouble or they fall
down a [__] hole bleep there's a full
tectonic load hanging off our ass what
if we turn off the gravity tezzers drop
the load by ourselves time I tried
unless I rip out half the ship's wiring
it takes the CEC board members override
to drop all that ore can't risk beeping
off the shareholders and without that
centrifuge to balance the ship we're
talking plan to fall in hours if we're
that lucky
so literally this was minutes before we
arrived because I've been here for maybe
over an hour or so
there ain't exactly that much time to
dick around
ah fun
zero gravity I'm entering zero gravity
centrifuge offline please attach
generator modules manually uh uh what if
I say
hello
oh oh oh
no no
gross I don't know what that's about
I don't want to know what that's about
I don't care what that's about
what
are you doing where where
oh there there we go
get shooted
that's more like it
anybody else want some
anybody else
that's what I thought s would have
thought
I just would have thought okay so I
gotta attach these damn things down here
manually
totally fine
[Music]
uh-huh
it's one good one
okay and there's another one easy to buy
who where
are you at where there you are
no whoa whoa whoa
foreign
no no no oh no that was plasma where'd
it go don't block my view now
oh where did it go you son of a [__]
you son of a [__] you just cost me some
goddamn plasma God damn it where did it
go
you go Hulk I looked away from it was
fine
fine it's not that big a deal
what am I doing
activate egg console what console
no that's not where I'm supposed to go
there's a console somewhere here and all
I gotta do is I gotta push a button over
here yeah here we go
okay
anyone see a plasma
no
there we go with that
oh that's cool
establishing balance with tectonic load
tectonic load huh
okay
so I just gotta apparently
there's some reason I can't be in zero g
but I get it it's fine
I understand
looks like the centrifuge is back online
someone took it apart still need to
refuel the engines hurry Isaac we're
getting damn close okay where am I going
where am I going oh oh no no no no not
like this no
okay well that didn't go very well so
the centrifuges back online someone took
it apart you still need to refuel the
engines hurry Isaac we're getting damn
close to Egypt right I was supposed to
go this way not that way I get it
go run oh no
oh look out look out behind you
oh he had airpods in
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
shooting as hard as I can shoot
man I could use more rate of fire on
that
because if you run from the get-go there
we go Isaac that boy Isaac that's what
you were talking about that's what your
target that's what I'm talking about
that's what we're talking about but
what's over here this is something else
hello
there's really nothing
okay whatever you say
and I go up he's
because apparently this is the correct
path to go
no better way to do this
can I get some O2
O2 please
O2 that's stasis that's not what I'm
looking for oh hurry
yep
say I like saving save while I'm
drowning
asphyxiating much more difficult word to
handle but
technically correct
oh my god oh hi
all right two can play this game
oh a nice bulbous sack would be a shame
if someone shot it a whole bunch
can you oh
okay
thank you
have a lonely day
I feel like I should be able to squash
that but it doesn't let me so
I'm fine
whatever
really hope I don't have to go through
decontamination again
but I'll do it because that's my job
wait a minute why is it so dark
[Applause]
wow
huh
is this level one or level two level one
man why didn't I open it before then all
right
let's think about upgrading my pulse
rifle because
um it's uh apparently wanting me to use
it
okay
[Music]
just in case just in case because you
never know
how things are gonna go
let's go
I think we just go back to the control
room
pretty sure I've been in here already
yeah this is where the security
clearance got me but wait is it
I don't remember ever looking at that
okay whatever
all right let's get back up there
because I need to go to the shop
good love those elevators they are just
a trip
okay
again with the thumpiness of the music
you always make me think that
something's happening
oh boy what is that heat accumulator
bring this part to the bench to extend
the upgrade path and gain access to a
special upgrade
for what a plasma cutter okay uh
I mean cool
that's dope I'm gonna sell this so bad
so that stuff it's for nerds
so that stuff is for nerds who needs two
of these not me I'm too good to be uh
bad
I do love the plasma cutter though
I love it it's my pride and joy it's my
baby oh I'll be able to afford the other
one when I come down that path later I
don't think there's a bench in here I
think the bench might have been only in
there but honestly who knows
I do not know
and I do not care because I'm just gonna
go wait a minute
but wait a minute if that's over there
then what's over here
what sound is long ominous hallway
ah it's the tram
oh well this is nothing I thought it was
a long ominous hallway of Doom turns out
it was just a tram
there I was worried over nothing
all right Ram
he is thank you for that
for that
all right well that's good to know
anyway apparently there are back paths
connecting everything
and I get to go over here
where I get to do some more nonsense
by myself
oh hi
like my heart pounding like that is that
a face in the
oh no it's a rag
why is the music being like that
oh sorry um
that's not what I meant
what
oh
put him
all right
I don't know if I've ever used the
Ripper
I don't know if I ever have it sounds
like a really cool weapon
don't know if I ever have used it I
really truly don't
today could be my day
this could be my moment to do so
saying it out loud
hey a bench
hey oh my God why would you do that to
me
go
[Applause]
oh my God you can't just do that to me
my tender disposition
I don't think I have anything to
actually do anything about it but okay
special one applies damage over time
oh but I don't have enough nodes to do
anything about it so I'll come back to
it anyway
Ripper
lots of damage
but none for me please
none for me
calibration room
secure all tool guards okay
oh hi what autopsy report Dr Nicole
Brennan
rig identifies the subject was Junior
engineer David Swenson
subject was dismembered after falling
into Machinery allowing
so sorry
postmortem spasms
just contains a yellow vial seen in
other specimens
seeing this file react to dead or
bioprosthetic cells
the dead tissue is absorbed recombined
then reanimated
the bile shares genetic markers with
human DNA and
growth on the walls
it's all connected to the marker from
ages seven but
how
Dr kind steady the marker
Dr kindness vanished
unless he's got the survivors on the
mining deck
he'll rest easy now David
I promise
end log
I I don't know about that I don't know
if that's I don't know if resting easy
is going to be any part of that
okay well I I stumbled across a
secondary objective and I didn't even
notice it what is this flashing red and
ominous at me
someone needs to fix these lights
they're spooky
okay
anybody else
on a tussle
with the muscle
oh my God that way refuel the engine
South and a bathroom
I like bathrooms
oh a bathroom message good security
request retrieved
we need help out at engineering
Henderson your teeth he's pulling his
teeth out
all right
[Music]
what the hell is happening I don't know
he has no security request
Anderson East the medical Bay and a
shrink
yeah I don't know if anything's usable
at this point how does it oh no oh you
moved
[Music]
why would you do that
why did you move
oh wow
he died dancing
he died doing what he loved to do
and I can respect that
okay security too
oh but it looks so cool in there oh man
oh this is gonna be a fun thing
uh
so damn dark all the time
that sounds bad yeah I'm on it uh
I'm working on it
if I knew half of the things that I was
supposed to be doing at this exact
moment I'd do them
but I don't
from my being an engineer both in real
life and here I don't really know what's
going on
oh just that easy
restart
I thought I could shoot that
who else is there oh my God
how did you do that
how did you sneak up behind me like that
you guys are really testing my patience
and I don't know why there's an oxygen
refueling thing there wait did I go the
right way
something tells me I did not
I think it's supposed to keep going up
in a different way probably
yeah keep going up
okay Upson I go I go uppies
oh that's bad
can I stop that guy yet
can you open
hey can you not
go
oh were you not able oh God
huh you were probably trying to go for
this guy but he doesn't have a head
anymore and that's why I gotta remove
everyone's heads
I like saving it's not weird it's a
survival tactic and I'm surviving
you see a corpse
take the head off I was trying to make a
rhyme but I didn't hello
I sure wish I had something to throw at
you
what do you would you just spit at me
oh you look a little weird
hey I shot you
okay this is a little
ow
that hurt like a lot
[Applause]
there you go
I gotta use my Kinesis more
that's what you get that's what you get
that's what you all get okay but that
didn't do me any good because that is
still locked down
I still need to go refuel Engine South
that's what I'm looking for
so if I can get over to South I can
refuel and then I can be on my way to
doing whatever the hell I'm doing
it was it's something down here
oh
I see
how much ammo I got
[Music]
not as much as I'd like
I'm going back to Old plasma cutter
yeah I got I got questions about how
they designed this thing
but the only way to refuel It Is by
going across a giant chasm of
nothingness
seems a little precarious
uh
hey hey no hey give me this give me give
me oh give me the goddamn
oh if you guys could stop hitting me so
hard with the spit the spit the spit
does way more damage than it should
say that
stop
yeah yeah yeah
you ever think that it might be what you
deserve
you ever think
do you
um
I'm sure you don't
[Music]
fuel line's the primary engine and
damage the valves to hell and back we
just wasted an hour fixing them now we
need to restart the self-refueling
station but some jackass turned off the
power and locked up the circuit breaker
no engines we're gonna hit Planet fall
soon what now there's got to be someone
around here how to spareax this car go
I did hear that
what a coincidence
[Music]
oh my God samsies
cut off the arm damn it
okay well
Armstrong I say
who actually needs to hit anything
oh I can't do it that's what that guy
was talking about
so I gotta find a key to get access and
then be able to turn back on the power I
like saving and then I'll be able to get
the refueling connected and then I'll
start up the engines and then Hammond
will get us back on track hey it's a key
that's almost too easy
almost too easy
damn it Daniels
you made it thank God after the bridge
we thought the glad to disappointment I
barricaded myself in the computer core I
can hear them but I don't think they
know him later I think I've tracked down
your rig you're an engineering right
I'll get myself admin privileges maybe I
can help
okay good catching up everybody man I
love my friends
such good people
through thick and thin
thank you lilac nodes okay life support
lighting why do you always make me not
have the lighting
don't you realize how that's really
unfair why you got at me I could turn
off life support I guess
no I'll turn off the lights I can make
it hard mode and turn off
oh my God it's dark oh my God
oh
is Pitch Black
what but but
okay
all right how do I get over there again
oh I gotta go up okay okay but it's just
dark I could deal with the Darkness
Darkness is fine
darkness is my Ally where find me where
where
no
I I thought I upgraded the damage to
this thing it seems to take just as many
shots as anything else
kind of curious about that I'm honest
babies
but it should be enough
sabotage
I'm gonna restart the entrance ready on
your mark
I'm gonna restart them
better watch yourself Hammond
I'm about to restart it
fine love this
God it's so much worse when I have to
choose to no don't what are you doing
oh
I get that
you dropped something I wanted there it
is oh why
you are the worst I hate you I was gonna
be fine and then I you wouldn't give me
your stick and I couldn't stab you with
your own stick and then you were just
being an [__] it's fine let's go back
we're done here
fine
oh why
why
oh
okay whatever it's fine
as is usual everything uh it's all in my
head
I'm actually wrong
hey
you are unfortunate
oh nothing a tactical Retreat can't
solve
ah
really nothing
I am an expert got it I like a few
storage is unlocked it'll give you
access to the engine chamber
okay whatever you say
uh Ricochet Tracer Ripper upgrade I
don't know how many uh nodes you think I
got I do not got that many I ain't got
the nodes
I love your confidence in me but uh I
ain't got it someday I'll use it but
today is probably not that day
I don't think I have enough money to
purchase a different upgrade either not
that it would do me any good I'm just
gonna save my money for now
I'm Gonna Save and then I'm Gonna Keep
plowing and get this engine started
before we plow into the planet which
would be very detrimental for my health
and probably you know but whatever it
costs the shareholders billions
where does this go over here
there's a thingamabob that says engine
room
but why
oh it's probably the way I come back
from if I had to guess use my big gamer
brain and know my gamer instinct's
pretty good that's probably gonna come
back from there
easy peasy
hi bud how you doing
I don't like you
your hair
oh
what do you mean this outbreak started
on the Colony after the miners dug up
some artifacts something alien that's
impossible but it would explain why ages
7 is meant to be off limits right Earth
gust orders when the miners found the
artifact they reported hallucinations
but the issue more brought this marker
on board anyway
wait
the marker okay back up where's this
marker now
okay
what was the sound
what was the sound I just heard
I also had an idea but uh
I'm assuming I was supposed to
shoot big or orange
[Music]
I have seen
videos that talk specifically about that
room I love that room
I often talk about that room
tangentially there is no purpose to that
room other than being very loud and
scary and it is horrible and I hate that
room but there's no danger to your life
in that room it is just a horrifying
room
we don't like the room there's no reason
for that room to exist and be that way
that it is but it is that way
oh fun also I got a flamethrower I feel
like I should be using it immediately
and burning everything in here all the
time forever that's a big orange
pulsating thing
I like that
oh
like the light oh
okay I don't like that thing
foreign
just checking I don't feel like leaving
you alive if you are alive
I don't know what you would call alive
in an experience like that but
don't like it security level three what
the hell is that supposed to be
I guess it would just behoove people for
going around and
re-exploring places
still not happy about it
I can't raise anyone on wriggling
I think my team is gone
I found the Kinesis module that someone
used to bust the Central Station
burned out
who would sabotage the ishimura at a
time like this
I'll report to the bridge
if anyone's left
and then I'm finding Elizabeth and
getting us the hell off this ship
well I hope you made it as a fellow
engineer you've got the best survival
skills apparently to get you through
this problem so I'm sure you're fine
don't like that
I'm gonna go ahead and put my
flamethrower on my bar I guess you and
right there all right I'm fully decked
out not that I'd know why but I'm Decked
Out
hello ah bench good
very good
I still don't know if I have enough
nodes for anything but
try I four oh good oh wow you know it
would be super dope to do anything about
that
but I really like the plasma cutter and
I really oh I could yep I'm going for it
I don't think I need these nodes to open
any door I'm going for it
that is
that's a slice of something special
that's a slice of something I like we're
good I'm using this thing
come here everybody I just want to show
you something then maybe burn you alive
[Music]
get off of me get off of me
get off of me
did you have something to do with that
why is it green
wait are you alive oh my God you are
hello
okay
up yeah the same outfit I do
[__] kind of looked like me but that
would be impossible all right no
personalsies
no personals can't be too safe
I mean he can be
clearance confirmed good wait wait good
yes almost missed it no
whoa you Mel
T bro
bro you melted whoa
that's sick
that's awesome
oh I love that I love that I love the
plasma cutter I truly do
nice
nice I clear out the elevator can I go
down now can I go down there no
no
did this not go down
really not go down elevator oh
ah
I'm just dumb it's over here tucked away
where I could never see it
why does it look like a Arena
holy God
don't why would you do that I don't know
how to do it
yeah
I forgot I had a flamethrower that would
have been much more effective than that
particular moment
ah
what no
good
you're dead my inventory is full are you
kidding me
no way
no it's not I hope that wasn't the three
pack oh no okay good I thought I used up
the three back
no thank you
all right well
this is going great everything's coming
up roses
no open I'll just back it up because I
was scared
okay
made it
barely though I don't know oh oh my God
damn I shoot fast get stomped
that's what I thought
what'd you get
I love this upgrade
I really don't want to deal with any of
you three two one
three two one
I don't like the trombones or whatever
the music that's playing when they come
out
immediately I'm working on it I don't
know what to do though okay which way do
I go
engine room yeah that that do make sense
control room
no
oh my go ahead sir
ah
why aren't you cute
aren't you guys cute wait a minute oh no
oh yeah stasis I'm gonna find me
something to shoot you with yes
oh okay
hey you're still alive
[Applause]
that's what you I just
get it into engine power failure
oh boy oh boy that ain't good
[Music]
okay got him
you're fine right
yeah fine
all good
all right engine failure soon
um ah should I hurry or what's the deal
power over here there's a power brick up
here
I know I know okay computer I am aware
of how things work
oh
why do I have a bad feeling about this
oh that's why
okay
man you guys get in a hurry when you're
when you know I'm coming for you
oh
what do I hear
hold on you no no no watch with your arm
I'm gonna beat the crap out of you
I said I'm just gonna blow you up
yeah
[Music]
okay why do I gotta confirm it you'd
think that it would be very obvious of
what I'm trying to do here and how you
were telling me that the whole ship is
going to go Blue into the planet but
whatever I guess I got to do it anyway
whatever it's fine
oh man I would have forgotten that
nice
let your tools do the talking I agree
I want to know what kind of tool that is
I know I'm just marveling at the
freaking V8 that this engine actually is
which is hilarious oh my God
it's probably fine
okay let's do this
schematics
sweet
okay primary engine
awesome
I'm probably not bathing me in radiation
at all all right I better forgot
something in here
all right we seem to be in good shape
let's get it out of here
mission's done oh I should probably
should have told him to actually uh
scoot us into orbit again but you know
how it is
Isaac you did it the issue more is
moving again no thanks to whoever
sabotaged the [__]
you bought us time to figure it out
autopilot is taking us into
geostationary orbit
wait you're flying us through
that's what the Asteroid Defense System
is for but the ads is offline I've got
the system readouts here Hammond the
instrument is a rough shape a couple of
bad strikes could finish her off [__]
Daniels give me all the data you have
I'll try to adjust course
Isaac take the train from engineering
meet me on the bridge I'll lift the
station lock down we need to work on
this together
I like friends I like my friends we're
gonna work on it together
whoa I just got a call from a girl
hey
why are you going to be doing that
that was mcgoyle who's squonking
I don't know what the squonkin is I
don't want to know what this pumpkin is
so I have an idea
it may not work
but hear me out right
Ripper
it's cool or whatever I
I need it flamethrower
hella cool
I'm thinking I might not need it
if I just have
you know what I need and not what I
don't it's not even gonna give me what I
don't need and I'll be able to focus on
what I do need
ah
I'm either really smart or everyone's
like no you're stupid no
no that and focus on just those it gives
me the maneuverability I need plus the
and then it'll move and then Bobby's
yeah I know right
I am a genius I'm glad you noticed God
so good at noticing things hmm that's
one of my favorite things about you how
good you notice can you notice how much
I like saving can you notice why kids
love the taste of Cinnamon Toast Crunch
can you notice my sweet Dead Space shirt
complete with rig in the back
can you notice it and can you notice the
link in the description that'll take you
right to cloakbrand.com where you can
see this and the entirety of our Dead
Space collab available now for a limited
time
can you notice that I bet you can with
those sharp eyes of yours beautiful
doesn't matter how bad your vision is
don't don't make any excuses I heard
that
doesn't matter your eyes still perfect
am I done I was kind of wandering back
to them oh wait this isn't the way to
the tram what am I stupid what am I an
idiot this
why didn't you notice that
didn't you notice that that I wasn't
going the way to the tram oh man you're
making me look like a fool maybe someday
I'll actually upgrade my rig some more
suit
they do get hit a lot and it would be
nice to be able to not die all the time
I've only died twice but practically all
the time and let's play talk that's
that's basically all the time
oh
looks like we're all done
thank you everybody for joining me on
this journey there will be more Isaac
Clark very very soon
thank you and as always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye